you know the only experience that i
really had with death is i was in the
room when my father passed and and this
is why i'm gonna i'm gonna tie this into
the theory that you just gave us
and um
when my father passed i was in the room
and uh the nurse all the all the uh
equipment went flatline and the nurse
goes that's it and you know we were
called to the hospital because we knew
that he was he was slipping away and she
goes that's it and she starts taking out
all the tubes and whatever and the
whatnot
and for whatever reason i can't i can't
articulate this but i felt
um an energy like he was still in the
room and the best way that i can explain
it have you ever been in a room
someplace and you feel like somebody's
watching you and you turn around and
there is somebody in the doorway and you
just felt they were there their presence
have you ever felt that eric
um before seeing somebody
i think the average person we don't
think about it has felt somebody's
presence looking at them near them and
then they turned around and they were
there i think the
your answer to this or
the story you just told gives us a piece
of that answer and that is we are this
magnetic electromagnetic being or that's
part of our being so you feel the energy
you know we give off energy whether we
give off heat whether we give off sound
we give off energy so people know when
you're in the room there is a feeling to
have another living creature live
even without
hearing you feel that and when she told
me my father
was
gone
for some reason i just had and this was
like before any of this stuff with that
happened well the one thing happened
with jackie with the house but none of
the stuff where she was in contact um
they were taking out the things and i
could feel my dad was still in the room
my dad was in the room but he wasn't in
this body that i was looking at and i
can't articulate but he was in the room
and i screamed at the top of my lungs i
screamed dad dad
and
he
went back into his body and took one
more
he took a uh a breath like that the
nurse jumped back and went [ __ ]
you know like even verbally said [ __ ]
and then i saw my dad was suffering i
said no you can go you can go you can go
you can go and it was the last breath
and i felt that energy leave that body
and leave the room
that
and that was it you know and then there
was just a body just that envelope there
but what i'm saying is i guess what i'm
saying to you and you know you can
believe me or not believe me that's what
i think i felt that's what i think i
experienced that's how i articulated but
it kind of makes sense to me when you
know i go to all these ekgs and for my
heart and i've had things done when i
realized there is
an energy in our body real energy and if
you follow science at all energy
cannot be destroyed it only changes
forms
that's
science
so if there is energy electromagnetic
energy that is what we are that is life
when this package we call a body is
damaged or broken or smashed where does
that energy go
and does that energy exist in any other
place and does it affect
other people in the world
that young man is your next theory that
i need you to solve
[Music]